one of the really sad and tragic things
that too often happens in bad situations
is that grifters come out of the
woodwork with new grifts that target
exactly the most vulnerable people at
any particular time in this case with
the coronavirus some of the most
vulnerable people are older folks often
who watch fox news often who watch
televangelist christian TV now I already
told you last week how this Christian
lunatic Jim Baker was told by the New
York Attorney General stopped promoting
this bogus silver solution cure for
coronavirus it's not a cure it can be
harmful to people's health drinking
silver solution and similar so-called
colloidal silver can make it so your
body doesn't properly absorb antibiotics
and other other medications they can
start to turn your skin sort of a bluish
gray it's bad stop saying it cures
coronavirus I have another one for you
today and it just so happens to be
another Christian lunatic
this one's Kenneth Copeland healing
people of the virus through the TV
Kenneth Copeland if you're not familiar
with him is this 83 year old
televangelist worth are reported 760
million dollars thanks to a very
successful multi-decade grift that he's
been running and he has used his grift
to fund private jets to fund a very
lavish lifestyle and here he is visibly
sort of sweaty with some kind of I'm
sure special healing water on his hand
healing his viewers mostly old folks who
are at risk through the TV during a very
quote special report called standing
against coronavirus we need vaccines we
need antivirals we need actual medical
treatments standing against coronavirus
with prayer through the TV is not what
we need but that's what he's offering
put your hand on that television set yes
thank you Jesus thank you Lord Jesus
he received your hailing yes
now say it I'll take it I have it I have
it's mine it's money I thank you and
praise you for it
yes and I forgive if I have aught
against any forgive and I praise you
that I'm well and hold I praise you that
I'm according to the Word of God
I'm healed yes and I consider not my own
body yes I consider not symptoms in my
body I consider not symptoms but only
that which God has promised only that
what the word has said by His stripes I
was healed and by His stripes I am
healed now I'm not the sick trying to
get healed
I'm the healed and the devil's trying to
give me the flu
three or whatever else kind of thing
he's trying yeah heal and well yes in a
sweet name in Jesus people are more
likely to die if they believe that this
works because they are more at risk of
dying if they get coronavirus because
these are older audiences that watch
this nonsense this should be illegal but
it's not
he makes gobs of money with this
nonsense and I hate to break it to you
but it's not just lunatic Christian
televangelists that are doing this Trump
has been doing it
Rush Limbaugh has been doing it Fox and
Friends has been doing it Trump tweeted
the day before yesterday a couple days
ago in His infinite orange wisdom and
leadership quote today is a National Day
of Prayer god bless everyone what we
need is a day of testing not a day of
Prayer we need a day of procuring
ventilators not blessings that we need
people to stay home not to go to
churches and if we're going to pray for
anything it should be for a competent
person to take Oh
for dealing with this pandemic crisis
and of course remember once you bring
God into it the obvious question is all
of this is just up to God why didn't God
stop coronavirus why did God allow or
create coronavirus wouldn't it be
simpler easier better instead of
creating or allowing coronavirus and
then waiting for people to pray enough
for God to stop it why not just skip
coronavirus altogether oval bow David
David God works in mysterious ways maybe
we haven't been praying hard enough
right we're done folks as a society if
this is what we're counting on insert
bogus lunatic talking point here this
stuff is truly vile it should be illegal
one of our sponsors today is VIN Chara
watches giving you 15% off your entire
order when you go to david pakman.com
slash watch don't pay thousands of
dollars for a high-quality watch that
looks great because you don't have to
all of inch arrows watches are made with
high-end materials masterfully built and
they look like something you'd spend a
ton of money on but ever even chero
watch ranges from about a hundred and
fifty to three hundred bucks I went over
to their website and picked out the
bellwether in silver and white really
nice elegant look it's a coronagraph
style wore it to a gala over the weekend
and a lot of people ask me where's the
watch from really really great look
totally different they also sent me the
altitude in matte black and red a much
more rugged view of what a watch can
look like really liked it as well as
well as the athletic strap it's a new
year it's a new decade it's time to
re-establish your style add something
new to your look and a high-quality
watch is the perfect way to do that you
can get 15% off inch arrows entire
collection when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch